hello good morning I am in Hawaii that
railing very very tropical sorry that
it's grazes up so late
I celebrated the fourth of July
yesterday look I got one of these top
bun things a lot of stuffs been going on
I am taking two days off here before
ahead to Austin yes Austin but memory
for more hay USA yeah so here's a little
look back at what some of the stuff
that's happened this week I really
didn't shoot very much guys I'm sorry we
shoot so much stuff for hate USA that
just watch it morning I'm at the airport
I miss gonna fight this morning for 10
minutes but at least my hair helmet made
it with me obviously
it tastes like soup
hey guys I'm in an airport what a
surprise it is day before fourth of July
and I'm flying back to the west coast
sort of hey USA it was being called the
place and I respectable
classy I am its day 4th July which is
America's birthday so probably the dome
in America I celebrated the Royal
Wedding didn't have a whole lot of time
to work on this but I'm in the video
here
you
no God
I don't know
see that human me he is yelling at
someone on the phone whereas for me
around